and so concludes this year's secret
santa drawing just a quick reminder of
the rules 48 hour limit no perishable
items and no homemade massage coupons
Hitchcock fine the number one I have to
pay full price for them Oh Captain I
would like a 40 gift card to any
restaurant that serves nachos I don't
have you Peralta not only do I know that
you do indeed have me but I also know
who everyone else has that's not
possible perhaps not for ordinary men
such as yourself Jeffords but for the
brilliant mind of detective Jacob
Sherlock Peralta I legally changed my
name it's quite simply
Elementary where you see Amy made a face
I only recognized from our bedroom which
means that she has Captain Holt Charles
has Terry his eyes keep shifting over to
him Terry looked disgusted which means
he has Hitchcock Rosa didn't draw a name
nor did she put one in she doesn't want
to participate never do Hitchcock moves
his mouth when he reads and he quite
clearly said Charles I did get Charlie
has Amy he's holding his paper named
side out oh he's good and I have Scully
which means Captain hold has me I'll be
taking that gift card Daddy loves nachos
should we draw the names again and leave
Jake out yeah
[Music]
very very interesting guys Captain hold
has no pants on
um
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts at 11 55 a.m Captain Holt
walked past us holding a hot bowl of
soup at 1203 PM I heard him yell
ouch then at 1207 he called Gina into
his office she entered holding nothing
one minute later she left holding an
opaque bag
Captain Holt's pants were in that bag
his knees are in the breeze he
that evidence is circumstantial oh so
you guys want visual confirmation not
really done
hey Captain I just need you to sign
something at my desk real quick just
leave it on the couch dismissed okay sir
you're gonna freak yo-yo my eyes in the
precinct and he's giving out autographs
Yo-Yo Ma is on tour in Australia right
now how would you know that
I'm choking on a lozenge I'm gonna die
amazing another bowl of soup since you
spilled yours earlier but you're gonna
have to come over here to get it all
right I'm sick of you wasting time so
yes I spilled some minestrone on my
pants and I'm sitting in my underwear
happy yes
ah
sir I need you to sign off on look at us
just three people with pants on having a
normal conversation yep no story here
this is nuts I can't believe hope
believes that ridiculous wind back in
his sack of Lies oh I know everything
about glitter and Drake's elbow Amy
please I just need your support right
now okay
wait a minute you believe me right of
course I do I'm your wife I'm on your
side no matter what thanks
Same by the way thanks I mean no one
really suspects me right look go home
I'll check for Prince in the Party Zone
receipt yours won't be there but maybe
someone else's will
Prince that's it I think I know who
framed me who I can't say yet I want to
be sure I want to do a big dramatic
reveal in front of everyone don't you
yes obviously look I have to go check on
one thing don't let anybody leave
attention everyone stop what you are
doing we are still a little Nazi I'm
gonna just drop the accent Peralta you
can't be here you're suspended and
you're lucky it's not worse the DA's
office want to do five I'm being framed
and I know who did it it was Dillman
I just met you today why would I do that
good question it's because you want Holt
to put you on that task force Stillman
can't be on a New York task force the
sfpd would never approve it correct only
he's not sfpd when you first arrived you
asked us to check the fingerprints
against the AFI system but that system
hasn't been used in over five years any
Police Department well I use the AFI
system for 20 years
I guess I misspoke misspoke I see that
explains everything my apologies I'm
just gonna head back on out to Exile
just to double back oh my God he's
double backing Donuts how could the best
detective of the Holtz ever worked with
make such a mistake I wondered myself so
I made a few phone calls it turns out
Dillman was fired by the sfpd I guess he
rubbed the brass the wrong way not only
that but he's currently working
part-time at Yarn Barn a hobby shop in
Albany I have his manager on the phone
right now Frank what is going on you
have a ship tonight you know I have
finals I'm I'm so sorry Alyssa I I got
hung up in the city I just lost track of
time this explains everything he's not a
great detective he's a sad man working
part-time selling crafting supplies okay
fine yes I was fired by the sfpd and yes
I contacted Raymond in hopes of getting
on that task force I thought it would be
my way back onto the NYPD oh my God I
hate The Yarn Barn really disappointing
to hear Frank yeah well you're a bad
manager Alyssa okay you play favorites
and it hurts to be on the outside I told
you not to lie what were you thinking I
thought it would work and I wanted to be
the one that got him this is about your
ego are you that desperate for everyone
to know how great you are it's not about
everyone okay it's just
I wanted you to know
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
he's not answering any questions that's
okay I have no questions that's right
I'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
I'm Phillip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diazepam has
said it if I take because I'm junkie
scum also for real addiction is a
disease I would be super empathetic if
you hadn't murdered a man what is the
point of this I'll get there so one day
I'm working late when my boss Robert
surprises me he found out I was stealing
meds again junkie's gone also again not
your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's
going to file a police report I could
lose my license we fight and something
in me just snaps so I grab the first
thing I can find and I hit him with it
you still have no mortar weapon I do now
here's a pic I found on Yelp of the
surgical Suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right I
can just tell you myself the Yelp shot
has six of these heavy Looking Glass
awards from the Brooklyn periodontics
Society in the background whereas this
shot only has five what happened to
number six you murdered Robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
everywhere but you got lucky you were in
the surgical Suite it can be sterilized
you never would have gotten away with it
in your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more and
your office manager would have heard all
of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you're wrong
you put Robert's body into a wheelchair
and shoved it in the elevator it's a
miracle there wasn't blood everywhere
that's not true now you're in the garage
with a corpse you panicked and left your
phone in your office and you don't have
your car keys but Roberts are in his
pocket so you put him in his car and you
take off you can't believe what you've
done no you're flustered you have no GPS
so you just start driving no next thing
you know you're in the Pine Barrens and
it hits you you're uncle's cabin he has
a place there you're the luckiest son
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no I knew exactly where I was driving I
left my phone in the office on purpose I
was in a surgical Suite by Design and I
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see what's missing I
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down it's already in a patient's
mouth son
oh damn
oh damn oh damn and that is 3-0 damn
fresh air
well I don't say that a lot there's one
thing I still don't understand
did you know you had the wrong murder
weapon oh excellent question sir yes I
spotted the missing Dental award when I
first took the case I asked around weeks
ago turns out a cleaning lady knocked it
over and shattered it then why did you
run in there like that because in
talking to you I realized what Philip's
worst fear actually was that we would
think he was just some dummy that got
lucky right he had planned the perfect
crime and it killed him when you said he
was sloppy and impulsive he needed us to
know how smart he was hi
like someone else I know
yep
Kevin
foreign